inspired by my most famous meme comes an
outrageous competition that finally
separates the colonary genius from the
idiot here at Caesar's Palace in Las
Vegas three contestants will go
head-to-head to create a sandwich that
will take the Internet by storm right uh
give it up for Lexi
first I love food I love food what's the
secret behind your breakfast sandwich
Lexi I watched all your scrambled eggs
YouTube videos that's
it it's going to be a breakfast sandwich
with some eggs some bacon some Chipotle
aoli love that sounds like a show
Lexi thank you that's my life right are
you guys
ready let's go is Vegas
ready your 20 minutes start
[Applause]
now the theme of today is the most
amazing breakfast sandwich so we want
something with texture we something that
picks me up and whether it's 6:00 in the
morning or or 3:00 a.m. in the morning
at breakfast sandwich literally is like
a meal in one I tried to study how
Gordon does his eggs cuz I know he's a
big scrambled eggs guy so I'm hoping
that'll win me over as well as doing a
special aoli sauce because aoli sounds
fancy oh my God why is that so heavy I
didn't know I had to work out before
this I really like the sandwich that I'm
making the king Elvis Presley would have
like big concerts he would always have
this super buttery delicious sandwich
now I'm doing my own take on that
basically peanut butter and banana is
the base it's kind of a weird combo but
I'm very excited going to start with the
bacon these are some nice pans I I don't
think I've ever cooked with a pan this
nice my man how you doing yes sir doing
good now tell me about this thing it's
full of culture I'm Filipino so we're
doing a Filipino breakfast sandwich so
you got that beautiful pork right you
got that beautiful longa love that and
how you cooking that uh so I'm going to
sear it off yes and then I'm going to
cook it down in water and all that Jew
I'm going to reduce all the way down uh
till where it becomes kind of a please I
love that can you do this today can you
win this thing 100% if you SI up the
competition are you worried about Sam
you worried about Lexi um open how do
you open it oh my God I'm not worried at
all love that I'm not worried at all oh
my gosh okay it doesn't have to be PR oh
gosh keep it going Lexie hi go you good
yeah I'm great how are you what are you
doing it's my special sauce what a
special canned sauce of Chipotle is that
it girl come on leg you know what Gordon
I'm doing my bus out here I love that
girl I love that right tell me about the
layers where where are we going with
this thing we got a Chipotle aoli
chipi next is that it we got cheese
scrambled eggs with some tries and then
on the bottom I'll do some bacon and
shallots sounds delicious um sizing up
the competition brand or Sam uh who's
the Fest competitor who are you worried
about Brandon he exudes confidence he
does doesn't he oh yeah that's that's
beautiful right uh 3 minutes gone Lexi
keep it going yes oh my God right uh
young man uh I love this idea love it
love it love it who taught you to cook
by the way who was the first big
influence my mom she would always just
make amazing meals especially for so
many of us every night and so just
whenever we travel to we love we love
eating does anyone ever tell you look
like the young Leonard
DiCaprio yeah I mean seriously now your
wife must be happy with that right I
yeah yeah she 15 minutes ago you got
this yes good luck come on give us some
love everybody let's go now secret
behind a great sandwich what is it it's
the butter and the cheese the butter and
the cheese the sauce the you're right
you're absolutely right come on big man
we got to have meat on it exactly that
guys we're halfway 10 minutes down 10
minutes to go come on guys give me love
please give them love SC I can't get the
shallot open and I'm panicking so Lexi
sounds a little bit familiar she's doing
a breakfast sandwich with a lot of
scrambled egg in there the problem with
scrambled egg inside of sandwich is it
drips everywhere so I'm not too sure
about that one Sam this guy is taking
advantage of that amazing upbring and
bringing a strong influence into this
sandwich sounds good Brandon one of the
most competitive in this Cookoff man
this guy knows what he's doing he's
using that beautiful pork rendering it
down and putting together this
incredibly textured sandwich he's so
competitive Brandon may actually run out
of time fingers crossed he doesn't you
know I'm feeling pretty good against the
competition I'm not going to lie I've
worked my ass off to be as good of a
cook as I am over the last 5 years or so
and so to be honest I'm not really
sweating it I just want to make sure we
get this done in 20 minutes right Lexie
how are we doing girl how's that secret
sauce it's not good look at the mess
W someone being sick what happened maybe
a little wait how do I shall I show you
are you going to chop it yeah what do
you need dice Circle what what do you
need like little dices little dices
anything else you need wow that's really
nice you've done this before haven't you
are we going to cook anything here legs
where's the scrambled eggs it we're
coming you know they only take 3 minutes
according to you there we go oh my God
we good let's go go come on 9 minutes to
go 9 minutes so Sam what bread are you
using uh I'm using a croissant bread wow
so something that Elvis would do is he
would do normal bread and he would get
an entire stick of butter and keep
flipping it until all the butter had
been absorbed into the bread croissant
already a little bit buttery so I won't
make you eat a whole stick of butter and
that's why he died of a heart attack at
39 yeah possibly we need to stay healthy
s i we need to stay healthy young man we
need health health health health don't
eat this sandwich every day just don't
eat it every day what's that on there
now peanut butter hold on peanut butter
with a fried egg yes and this is one of
Elvis's favorites so I added the egg
that's my touch gotcha okay good banana
peanut butter fried egg bacon man you
are loading up yep confidence every
every yes so minutes to go so this is
going to be my
sauce this is going toate the way I
wanted to but it's okay oh my God it's a
mess it's a
mess is it on I'm not sure if it's on oh
the multitask it's so burnt this is
bad Lexi I'm dying to see these
scrumbled eggs go I'm dying to see the
scrumbled eggs no that's okay Gordon you
can go away is
that Lexi 30 seconds is on 30 we're
running out of time I'm trying this is
I'm trying it it's going so fast and I'm
panicking okay try and hold the spatula
like this so we just sort of whisk it
round pull back yeah why don't you do
that and I'm going to go over here real
quick no that's great you're killing it
crushing it I'm going to go rub some
buns is there is there any butter in
here Lexi the egg's not as runny as I
want it just came apart a little bit I'm
just going to try and fr other egg real
quick see if I can get something better
we're down to 3 minutes remaining come
on guys give them some love everybody
Lexi taste everything please I'm so
sorry oh my god let's go okay Sam start
mounting that thing I'm going to wait
till the last minute to get this sausage
going look at the mess on your board oh
my God your mother's going to kill me I
feel so bad for whoever's cleaning this
oh that's not melting Brandon are
you good yeah you going to make this
yeah let's get some heat in that thing
let's go maybe I'll just take out the
burnt Parts 30 seconds to go finish and
touches Sam let's go Lexi Finishing
Touches well done that's pretty first
time using
this 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
1 Well
Done Right that was an extraordinary 20
minutes cheers how'd it go Sam good you
why do you have a fancy stick in yours
cuz it's kind of I didn't get a stick
hey it looks good it does look good in
all honesty this some parts of it looks
a little bit little bit under 20 minutes
20 minutes is tough 20 minutes is
tough uh visually is that what you
wanted it's all right it's what it's all
right oh it's right right I thought he
said it was shite it's not shite no it's
the tell me about the layers what's in
there uh Chipotle aoli scrambled eggs
with chives bacon and shallots in a
toasty bud so scrumble EGS look nice and
soft cheers oh
cheers
M that's nice really M it's really nice
really why why you look so nervous cuz
you're Gordon Ramsey no it's good girl
really good indeed really good indeed
right Sam I'm excited so visually it
looks delicious right I'm just wored
about Granddad
skidmark I I tried to get fancy but I
know it's I regret it it's peanut butter
right um the one doubt I had was that
egg in the middle but hey it's all in
the taste right oh look at that
okay egg is cooked to
Perfection too much peanut butter no no
no it's just the peanut butter and the
Egg weirdly it's delicious sound
yes that is a huge
relief now we got the egg fried we're
going to slice that down yeah and then
talk to me about the layers so we have a
rugal on the bottoms um we have the
longan some cheese a little bit of
pickled onions and then the Egg of
course so I love
that it's good it's good it's very good
well done thank you well
done wow right you three come over
please here we are the Moment of Truth
who is going to be crowned Our Idiot
breakfast sandwich was it Lex's
breakfast
sandwich
thank you was it
Sam's or was it
Brandon's and the winner
[Applause]
is what are you an idiot sandwich now an
idiot sandwich congratulations Sam
everybody Sam
good job thank you amazing amazing
amazing amazing delicious Bud thank you
I think you just started a craze peanut
butter and fried eggs own it my man okay
thank congrats give him a round of
applause everybody good job man good job
now show me your idiot sandwiches by
using the hash idiot sandwich and don't
forget to subscribe for more amazing
videos